Now that we're done with waves, let's move on to buoyancy.
Now buoyancy allows objects to float on top of the surfaces,
but not only just that,
we can actually have buoyant objects that are say in a river,
and they can actually use that river's velocity to drag them
from the river down to the ocean.
Now there's a couple of things that we need to do.
First off, we're gonna need to make sure
that we use the buoyancy component
and set up something called pontoons,
which allow us to see where things are floating,
or not see where, but work as areas
where things are gonna float from.
So let's go ahead and set this up now.
So what I'm gonna do is hit Control Space,
we're gonna right click, Blueprint Class,
base this off of actor,
we'll just call this BP Floating Actor,
and then double click on it to open it up.
Bring this over here so that we can see it.
So the first thing we're gonna add is a cube.
So we're gonna add a cube right here like so.
We do need to add a couple of other things.
So we're gonna make the cube the default scene root.
This is important because this has to happen
in order for buoyancy to work correctly.
Also with the cube selected,
we're gonna do a simulate physics,
and we're gonna set our mass KG enabled.
Then we're going to add a BU buoyancy component,
and then next we need to add a box.
You want this box collision,
and the box collision,
we're just going to pop it out once
so that we can go,
if we go out once like that,
and then bring it back in one,
we'll get a perfect box collision looking.
So if we go to our wireframe,
we'll see here it's exactly what we wanted.
And then what we need to do is select our buoyancy here,
and underneath the buoyancy,
you're gonna see a bunch of things
that we want to enable or adjust.
So first things first,
we're gonna go up to pontoons.
We're gonna go one, two, three, and four,
and we're gonna set this first one at 50 and 50,
and we're gonna change its radius to 50 as well.
And then for the next pontoon,
we're gonna go negative 50, negative 50,
and we're gonna set its radius at 50 as well.
So basically we're gonna be putting a pontoons on this,
or areas where this can float
in all four corners of our box.
So to continue to this,
we're gonna go 50, negative 50,
and then we're gonna set this one to 50 as well.
And then for this one, we're gonna go negative 50, 50,
and then finally 50 here.
So that is all we've done.
We've just literally set all of these to 50.
Then once we have done all of that,
we are gonna come here
and we're gonna apply drag forces in water,
and then we're gonna allow lateral push,
allow current when moving fast upstream
and apply downstream angular rotations
that things will rotate,
because we're gonna make one
that kind of does all of our needs.
So let's go ahead and compile and save.
And once we run this,
what we're gonna be looking for
is something kind of similar to this,
where we have all of these objects out off in the distance,
and as we drop them in,
they are gonna come from the distance
into the actual beach,
and the same thing with our river.
So let's pop over here to our editor,
and I'm gonna close this,
and let's go up here and try this out right here.
So we're gonna hit Control Space,
we'll bring in our floating actor,
we'll put it right above this,
close that, and then we're just gonna hit Alt S to simulate,
and let's see what happens.
So there we go, it's coming through,
it's bobbing up, all right, that's working.
Now you can see it is moving,
so it's starting to get some speed there.
And there we go, it's starting to take off,
it'll go down, and that's pretty cool, right?
It's being pushed along with that river,
and we didn't have to do anything
other than add our buoyancy component here.
So let's go ahead and we'll hit Control Space again.
This time though, I'm going to maybe increase this
to a value of five, bring it up a little bit,
let's just hit Alt S to see what will happen,
and check this out.
And yep, there we go, it's kind of bobbing along.
Now there is one command that we can use here
if we want to diagnose what's going on.
If we enter the command r.water.boyancydebug set to one,
this is going to show us the water debug.
So those little red things that you're seeing here,
those red spheres, those are our pontoons
that we set up before, okay?
So you can see them, they are covering
the entire object there, and we can see them
kind of over here as well.
So this, and the green area is showing us
how this is simulating with the surface.
So we're basically running a simulation underneath
the surface that we are then mapping this buoyancy to,
and that is how we can see these waves.
So if I go ahead and hit stop here,
and maybe I just make a couple more of these, whoa.
You can see some really awesome results
that we can do with this.
So let's just hit Alt S,
because the last little tip that I want to leave you with
is this, if we, I'm just going to hit stop really quick,
if we come to one of these and we hit control E
to open it up, and we are simulating,
we can actually grab our buoyancy here,
and we can start to adjust some of these parameters,
and we can see what the effect is going to be
on the buoyancy kind of in real time.
It gives us a better idea of what is going on
so that we don't necessarily have to restart
our simulation each time.
We want to just kind of understand
what these values are doing
and how they affect our objects.
Remember, if you do want to disable, oops,
and I didn't want to do that,
what I wanted to do is hit F and then hit the Alt S again.
If you want to get rid of this little debug here,
that's, remember, we just need to come back to our console.
I'm going to press up and then set that back to zero,
and we will get rid of that debug information,
and we'll have back to this view right here.